So going back here, with out four issuing order processor with
perfect branch prediction, we have seen that our loop, gets a CPI of 3 over 5,
which is 0.6. Without scheduling, and it gets a CPI of 2 over 5.
Which is 0.4, if we do a scheduling on the original loop. Now let's see what
happens when we unroll the loop once, and try to execute it on this processor.
This is the code we constructed, and now what happens in this loop is we,
do the load. The add has to wait for that result. The store has to wait for
that. This load is going to a different memory element, so it can proceed
in parallel with the store. The R however, has to wait for that load. And then,
this store has to wait for that add. And then, this decrement of the pointer,
can proceed in parallel with the store, But the branch has to wait for R1.
However then, the load can proceed. And now, we are back to where we started.
So overall, it takes us five cycles. Do do these 8 instructions,
which gives us a CP of 0.62 slightly lower than the original
on schedule loop but not much lower. So these are very similar in CPI,
we still gain significantly from eliminating some instructions. So
overall this loop is going to perform better but the CPI has not improved. But
let's see what scheduling does after enrolling. In the scheduled loop, we will
have our load, for the first iteration of the two that we are really doing. And
now if we put the add here, it would again have a dependence, so the load and
whatever we did here would be the only thing that can be done in this cycle.
So instead of doing the add next, we will look for what else can we do here that
doesn't depend on this load. And it turns out that this load here, the load for
the second iteration, can be done in parallel with this load. However, we cannot
store the value into R2, so we will have to use another register, let's say R10,
for that. So these two now can execute in the same cycle. And if you remember so
could the branch. Now that we have done this we can do the add for the first
iteration of the loop, and also the one for the second iteration of the loop,
in the same cycle and in the same cycle you can do the add i instruction for
moving the pointer. Now these two will produce the results that the stores need.
So next cycle, we can do the stores. Note, however,
that this is the store that was supposed to store with offset 0 from R1, but
here, we have now decremented R1 by 8. So now we need to store to
8 from R1. That's because his store needs to match the [UNKNOWN] of this load,
but the R1 has moved in between. And then for the other store,
we're storing R10 now, to the address that used to be minus 4 from R1.
But R1 has already moved by minus 8. So now we need to store to 4 from R1,
to match the address of this. This is basically minus 4 and then,
we did minus 8, so now we need to add 4 to that, in order to get minus 4. And
now, we can do our branch. So now let's see what can we get on our processor.
In the first cycle we will be doing these two loads that can now proceed in
parallel. The Add here, however, cannot proceed in that same cycle because
it needs a result of this load. However, this Add, and the next one,
and this one can proceed in the second cycle. Then the stores here have to
wait the results of the adds so they cannot proceed in the same cycle.
However they can be done in the next cycle and so can the branch because the R1
has been produced, and so can the load because R1 has been produced. And
unfortunately in this cycle we can not do this load because we already executed
four things so unfortunately that load is done in the next cycle after which we
get the same schedule as here. The three adds, and so on. So overall,
it took us now 3 cycles to do 8 instructions. Which gives us a CP of 0.38,
slightly better than the scheduled CPI for the loop that we didn't unroll.
So what really happened is unrolling gives us more stuff that we can
reorder here so that we can find more things that don't have dependencies and
thus for example, we were able to do these two loads that were
not available prior to unrolling. If we unroll this loop three times,
then we will have four loads here that can all proceed in the same cycle.
We will have four adds here that can proceed in the same cycle. Four stores that
can proceed in the same cycle. And then the Add and branch equal. So
the more we unroll, the more parallelism we can get, simply because there is no.
More instructions among which we can try to find independent ones.
Keep in mind, that unrolling already reduced a number of instructions and
with scheduling it allows us to also reduce the CPI so
it kind of creates a double whammy. For performance improvement our
execution time gets reduced both because we have fewer instructions,
8 instructions per 2 iterations as opposed to 5 instructions originally for
one iteration. And also after scheduling it gives us usually a better CPI.